[Music]  you have interrupted a citywide  investigation you stole evidence from my  crime scene and you got my one lead  killed I was trying to help him but you  didn't just stop talking who the hell  are you  My name is Matthew Murdock I'm an  attorney  how does being Harlem's hero allow you  to live an actual life right now I just  want to help people I think there's  something that you need to meet hey who  are you who are you  how come you can't be hurt  what's the deal with that fist I'm the  immortal iron fist you what you're on  the same side you for the devil of  Hell's Kitchen the smartass detectives  we got a problem  the righteous X Cohen and the kid with a  glowing fish the war for New York is  here so get your [ __ ] together more  connections you have  whoopee - Frankie like an idiot  gosh  you make quite a chin now what are you  talking about bulletproof blind ninja  whatever it is you are classy  [Music]